alex kerloff just called up from the
alternative site he's going to start
in left field and batch six hopefully if
it's a little bit
warmer for us it's a little bit warmer
down on the field yeah and hopefully a
little better for
seeing for the hitters maybe that'll
make a difference a tough day yesterday
but no snow falling today no snow
expected
he's been good he's been what you hope
for out of your opening day starter
you look for a guy like him to go out
there
and stop this short three-game losing
streak that the twins have going right
now and
couldn't draw it up any better with maya
and barrios going game two but
your focus right now is only on winning
game one you can't worry about
winning game two until you get through
game one so he's gonna have to use his
fastball
and then obviously he gets his outs a
lot of times with his change-ups in his
slider so he's gonna mix his pitch as
well keep these red sox hitters off
balance and look for him to get off to a
good start
just got a piece of it that's a good job
right there because that was a nasty
split and the catcher was able to hang
on to it
a foul tip and held and it went for a
strikeout can that ball hit the ground
that's a foul ball umpires getting
together because the umpire did not see
the ball hit the ground right and then
come up into the thigh of jeffers
so yeah i'd be shocked if this isn't
overturned it's got to be
well guess what nobody saw it and it is
going to be a strikeout oh that's not
that's not good at all
wow so this double header doesn't start
well for the red sox
and the 1-1
lined into the alley that's going to
drop down for a base hit
carol off will scoop that verdugo on
with a solid single here with martinez
coming up
oh vadugo no history against maeda but
uh
jumps right on that that pitch right
there and takes it to the opposite field
for the base hit
a panic in the streets of boston jd
martinez is old for five he hit two
balls on the button yesterday it could
have been hits with one out full count
he's running
and it's high and tight for ball four
so red sox have something brewing right
away
against one of the best pitchers in the
american league that's the old saying
you know when you get a good pitcher you
know get him early as possible and
bogart's swinging it pretty good for the
red sox just two runs batted in
popped up and field fly rule should be
called
and is
catches made by arai's two down and
that'll bring up rafael devers first
inning
here comes he got him strike three a
fastball at 92. so the red sox make
noise don't score maeda strikes out
devers and the red sox strand a pair
he's
had a real good start he's he's high
velocity on everything he's he's a power
pitcher even the off-speed stuff is
going to be upper 80s to low 90s he's
really coming at you and you got to get
it ready from the first pitch
liner to the second baseman arroyo two
down and that'll bring up nelson cruz
was sent home yesterday he wasn't uh
feeling well yesterday they sent him
home still not a hundred percent the 1-1
pitch a ground ball smash fair inside
third down the left field line
this one scoots on the dirt and finds
the left field corner nelson cruz
welcome back a two-out double
left is bad at 110 miles an hour a
two-out extra base hit
here's the pitch and he swings and
grounds a breaking ball to the second
baseman right at arroyo flips to first
and that retires beside the double
armlet after one no score no score in
the second the pitch low he there is a
splitter and it's in the dirt guard
gonzalez the second and he slides and
he's safe that's a good base running by
marwan you know you got a guy with split
sliders so you anticipate balls in the
dirt you're not stealing you're not a
base dealer however
you know
maybe you pick up the sign from the
catcher maybe you can pick up something
from the pitcher and identify a split
red sox putting some early pressure on
kenta maeda in the twins
two ball two strike pitch and he swings
and lines one into left center field to
base hit this should get a run off purl
off back hands fires it into the middle
of the diamond and scoring on the play
is gonzales and the red sox lead at one
nothing
he's on first and second red sox trying
to make it four consecutive hits against
maeda and plowecki hitting right at 300
squaring he bunts he rolls it toward the
pitcher maeda has it fires the third he
throws it away it goes into foul ground
a run is scored hunter renfro crosses
the plate and over the third goes
francie into second base is plowiki
maeda with a terrible throw i mean he
air mailed it that was 15 feet over the
head of the third baseman
and i think he would have had a play as
maeda hands on his knees force that
commits a throwing error and the red sox
have a two nothing lead two on and still
nobody out in this troubling second
inning
red sox jump out in front two to nothing
in his one-two pitch
hard hit base hit
in to score cordero
down to third plawecki three to nothing
red sox
arroyo striking again swinging a hot bat
now three nothing in favor of the red
sox twins bullpen quiet so the runners
moving up one base and a single now will
get the twins right back in the game any
type of good contact should get a run in
another 3-2
that's up the middle and through for a
hit
great at bat for polanco it'll plate two
and it's a 3-2 ball game
well he kept fouling off tough pitches
fouling off tough pitches keeping the
at-bat alive real good job of just
continuing to grind it out and then ends
up getting rewarded with a base hit up
the middle and
now you've got the go ahead run come to
the plate and nelson cruz
under his chin and hit him
rushed his hand apparently
and ivaldi having
every bit the difficulty in the third
inning that maida had in the second yeah
cruz
didn't like that much any hitter doesn't
like that ball up in that area and
obviously no intent he's in an o2 count
he's just tried to reach back for a
little something extra and lost
a little bit of control of that pitch
and the pitch number out in front of
home plate could be picked up by ivaldi
he'll throw to first to retire
off the deal twins get two runs on the
board they strand two new score after
three
now ready to go
jeffers sets up away
and the pitch is swung out of miss got
him
chased the slider down and away good
pitch
and cody comes in and picks up a couple
of big strikeouts
they strand one twins coming to bat they
trail by one three two red sox sixth
inning one on one out
here's the 1-1 pitch line drive left
center field coming in kirloff slides
and makes a fine sliding catch
for out number two
that was hit sharply off the bat at 106
miles an hour do or die try there from
kirloff down to the ground a feet for a
sliding catch and a huge play for out
number two
it started with a double and a single
and waddell one good pitch away from
leaving the bases full and the 2-2 pitch
has popped up right side osterdio
capping the right hand glove on the left
he measures on the grass he's got it and
that's out number three
brandon wandel in a jam but no further
damage done the red sox leave the
maximum
so miguel comes within a foot of tying
the game next pitch strikes out two out
and outs up to luisa rise
here's the 3-1 home
breaking ball that one swatted line
drive and a diving play out there in
left field by verdugo to end the ball
game you got to be kidding me
a sprawling stab
and the game is over and the red sox
have made it eight in a row